today rtc announced it's making draft  day transportation a little easier for  locals all across the valley with game  day express transit service there will  be buses going back and forth about  every 20 minutes throughout the whole  draft weekend  and we broke down all the main routes  for you on this map there are stops all  over the place from red rock casino up  in summerlin to santa fe station in  centennial hills we've also got boulder  station on the east side green valley  ranch and the m resort we're told there  will also be a bus for folks in the  downtown and north las vegas areas with  multiple stops at cashman field the mob  museum and the bonneville transit center